[موسيقى]
الروسيه تثير الجدل
وتحديدا عام 2014
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم
بانها الغطاء الذي تمارس من خلاله روسيا
نفوذها في مناطق نزاع عديده في العالم ومع
تصاعدي دورها في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
يزداد الجدل بشانها حتى ان المتحدث باسم
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي اكد ان لديها
ما يقرب من 50,000 عنصرين منتشرين في
اوكرانيا وان الرئيس الروسي اصبح يعول
عليها
للوقوف على بعض ملامح عمل هذه الميليشيا
وحجم قوتها ومناطق تداخلها المختلفه
يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ
الدراسات الامنيه والاستراتيجيه في معهد
الدوحه للدراسات العليا من موسكو فيكتور
لتبكين الخبير العسكري والعقيد والاحتياطي
في الجيش الروسي ومن واشنطن الدكتور حافظ
الهويل الكبير والباحثين في معهد السياسات
الخارجيه في جامعه
فاهلا بهم جميعا
متغيرات سياسيه وعسكريه جديده ظهرت في
السنوات الاخيره في اوكرانيا والشرق
الاوسط وافريقيا لها علاقه بصراع مراكز
القوى نشاط ميليشيا فاكنر احد ابرز هذه
المتغيرات خاصه وقد تجاوزت قدراتها
العسكريه ما لدى اي شركه امنيه غربيه خاصه
وذلك بفضل دعم الكريملين الذي اتخذها
وسيله لتامين وجوده وتوسيع نفوذه في مناطق
مختلفه من العالم
[موسيقى]
ثاني بعد
مباشر
[موسيقى]
سنوات
قتاليه خاصه خلال خدمتهم في مناطق ساخنه
من العالم
انها خبره من النوع الذي قد لا تقدر عليه
الجيوش النظاميه فهؤلاء المرتزقه لا
يتقيدون بقانون ولا يخضع قادتهم للمساءله
هذا ما يتطلع اليه الطموح الروسي الذي
يقول موقع
اساسيون من استراتيجيه روسيا الاوسع
المتمثله في الحرب الهجينه التي هي مزيج
من العمل العسكري والاعلامي لتعزيز
المصالح الروسيه
تحقق وجود مقاتلين من هذه الميليشيا في
اوكرانيا اولا ثم في سوريا في ليبيا وصولا
الى افريقيا الوسطى والسودان ومالي ليس
هذا التوسع مجرد صدفه فحسب تقرير النشاط
وهي منظمه الاستقصائيه وسياسيه بين الكريم
ليسعى الى التمركز في نطاق الجغرافي واسع
في افريقيا هدفه من ذلك الوصول الى
الموارد الطبيعيه وتعزيز النفود الروسي في
القاره الغنيه
انها شبكه من المصالح تتداخل فيها المنفعه
السياسيه بالارباح الاقتصاديه ففي حاله
افريقيا الوسطى مثلا ابرم بوتين صفقه مع
رئيس البلاد ارشاش وديرا عام 2018 لدعمه ب
400 مقاتل من ميليشيا فاغنر في مواجهه
سيليكا المسلحه مقابله حصول موسكو على حصص
من مناجم الذهب والماس في شمالي البلاد
انها صفقه تختصر حسب بعض القراءات توجهها
روسيا لتوسيع النفوذ بوسائل اقل تكلفه
واكثر فاعليه مستقله طموح جاعمات
الافريقيه لتحصين بقائها في السلطه الان
وقد بدا الغرب يفرض عقوبات جديده على
ميليش
اكد ذلك مسؤول كبير في الاداره الامريكيه
قال ان كوريا الشماليه سلمت شحنه مبدئيه
من الاسلحه الروسيه ويخش ان مزيدا من
العتاد العسكري في الطريق فكيف سيواجه
الغرب هذه العصا الغريبه للكريم لان في ظل
صراع مراكز القوى في العالم
ابرز المراحل والمحطات التي مرت بها
ميليشيا فاجنر في الورقه التاليه
[موسيقى]
دكتور عمر عاشور اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف سعد النجوم في هذه السنوات بهذه
السرعه هذه قصه تسعه سنوات
يناير 23
بحجم خمس فرق نظاميه وحاول تقديرات ما بين
40 الى 50,000 همم قوه اسلحه مشتركه
مضارعات متدفعيه قدرات على حجم الطيارين
خطوات على همم لحشد المشاه قدرات
استقباريه قدرات الكترونيه بعض الدعم من
الجيش النظامي
ولها بعد سياسي واضح زعيم وهو يقول همم ان
من من كافه القوات الروسيه الموجوده الان
في اوكرانيا هذه هي القوه الوحيده التي
تتقدم يعني في في ديسمبر يناير همم تراجعت
المرحله الثالثه من الحرب بتراجعت القوات
النخبه في خرصان قوه
تراجعت للجبهه همم
الجنوبيه من نهر على الضفه الاخرى الضفه
اليسرى من خرسانه
وفيها كيف انهارت القوات هناك هو كان يعني
القوات المنطقه العسكريه همم شامله القوات
الجيشات الانفصلين في ال- همم مهندس
هؤلاء ايضا انهاروا
وفي الحالتين سواء كان انسحاب منظم كما
حدث في غصون او انهيار كما حدث في هاركف
هذه كانت قوات نظاميه تتراجع
لتتمطرز خلف خطوط دفاعيه افضل الوحيدون
الذين كانوا يتقدمون كانت فاجنر في
جبهه ضخمود واجابات
عن الجيش الروسي حتى تكون بهذه الكفاءه
القتاليه هو هو يعني هذه ايضا معقد هذه
خبره سنوات لكن هو ليس التمييز هو يعني هم
الاوكران كانوا مستهدفين خرسان وكانوا
مجتهدفين همم هارف كيف والذين قتلوهم همم
في خصام كانوا تقريبا لا يمكن دعم
لجوجلتين لانهم كانوا على ضفهم وغيره من
النهر وكان الامتداد لهم صعب الغايه وقطعت
كافه همم يعني ليس كافه العديد من الخطوط
امدادهم خطوره الانسحاب والذين وجوههم في
خارف كانوا بقايا المنطقه العسكريه
الرابعه التي سحقت في معارك جنيف وتسومي
بقايا الفالق الحادي عشر من كالينغراد
الذي تقريبا دمر في ايضا معارك شمال الشرق
في اوكرانيا
وبليشيات الانفصاليين التي لم تكن يعني
بهذه الحاله وبعض عناصر الوزراديا الحرس
الوطني الروسي فكان يواجهون لنقل ليس
النخبه ولكن في في هذه الحاله تحديدا همم
وجدنا امران الامر الاول يقوه عدديه هائله
تمثلت بالحشد وذكرتم الحاج من السجون
نتكلم عن اكثر من الذين وقعوا الكونفكس
بتقطيرات 30,000 30,000 ثلاث فرق همم
القدره على
السجون من السجون وحدها غير غير المجموعات
المجموعات ذات الخبرات ال 10
الافاضلات هؤلاء الذين نجحوا في 10 سنوات
او تسع سنوات منذ فبرا 2014 لانها متورطه
في اوكرانيا موجوده فبراير 2014 هؤلاء
يعني تراكم خبرات هائل همم لديهم من ناحيه
وبعضهم يعني مؤسس لمترو كان كلام القوات
الخاصه اللي همم الاستخبارات قوه خاصه
للاستخبارات العسكريه الروسيه والذي خبره
في حربين حرب الشين الاولى وحرب الشين
الثانيه ومعهم مجموعهان وهو ربما
وهو العديد يعني هم يحشدون من السجون
يطلقونهم ليثبتوا القوات الاوكرانيه حتى
لو خسروهم لا توجد مشكله همم يكملون وهي
نفس الطريقه التي همم يعني نقول انها جربت
في وهرانك حين سقطت المقاطعه كامله في صيف
همم 22 كانت نفس الطريقه التي حدث في
تشكيل يثبتون بقوات لا يحتاجون هذالز
ويلتفون بعد ذلك على القوات الاخرى لان
الخبراء في همم يستطيع ان يقوم بهذه
المباراه هو الغريب سيد همم
في موسكو وان القانون في روسيا لا يسمح
بشركات امنيه خاصه حتى انا فاجنر مسجله
كشركه في الارجنتين هذا ما هذا ما كتب
عنها على الاقل
ما طبيعه العلاقه
بين فاجنر والمؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه
الرسميه
منفوخه اكثر من الواقع الحقيقي في الواقع
هناك
هي عباره عن شركه خاصه عسكريه تقوم
يخدم بها ضباط الاحتياط او المتقاعدين
الذين
تجمعوا لحلول مهمات عسكريه على اساس عقود
مع حكومات او مع شركات لذلك هناك بالطبع
ممكن ان يخدم
المساجين او الذين يقومون بتقديم طلب انهم
يريدون ان يتوبوا عند نوبهم بخدمه الوطن
وليس هناك اي شيء غريب في هذا النظر ليست
الشركه الحربيه الوحيده في العالم على
سبيل المثال همم هناك
10 شركات
حربيه هي الافضل في العالم منها اربعه
امريكيه منها بلاكادو التي انشهرت في
امريكا وقامت بكثير من الجرائم في العراق
وكان استخدم الولايات المتحده وهي الان
لديها اسم اكاديميه
وممثلين هذه الشركه الخاصه موجودين في
سوريا يقومون بسرقه السوري مع الامريكيين
ويبيعوه
ويقومون بزيادهم على هذا الاساس ووجودهم
في سوريا كل الجيش الامريكي تماما غير
قانوني ولا احد يسميهم بالارهابيين همم
العجيب همم وهذا شيء عجيب بحد ذاتها اما
فاجنر نعم هم
شاركوا في ماله وهمم وفي افريقيا
هو لا اعلم هل كانوا موجودين في ليبيا ام
لا قد يكونوا تواجد وساعدوا السيد حفتر
هناك ولكنهم كانوا موجودين في سوريا بشكل
علني وهذا شيء معروف
عندما تقول اسمح لي بالمقاطعه عندما تقول
لا عيب في ان سجين يتوب ويريد ان يخدم
الوطن لماذا لا يخدم الوطن في الجيش لماذا
يخدم في هذه الشركه الخاصه اذا كان يريد
خدمه الوطن خدمه الوطن وخدمه العلم مع
الجيش الرسمي ليس مع شركه امنيه خاصه
في الجيش العسكري الرسمي لا يجوز قانونيا
ان يخدم شخص كان له ثوابق قانونيه او
جرائم اما في الشركات الخاصه هذا مسموح به
هناك
وسيله لاختيار الجنود للخدمه في العسكريه
الرسميه او الشركات الخاصه وهي قانوني
قوانين مختلفه تماما لا يستطيع ان ينضم
للجيش على سبيل المثال شخص عمره 50 سنه
ولكن في الشركه الخاصه هذا شيء جائز في
الجيش الرسمي همم يقوم كل شخص بالخدمه حسب
رتبته العسكريه ولكن في الشركات الخاصه
ممكن ان يشارك باي درجه وباي رتبه جندي
حتى وليس هذا شيء غريب لذلك ممكن ان ينضم
اي سجين يريد ان يتوب
يكثر عن همم جرائمه
على سبيل المثال في الدباس كان هناك شخص
اشترك في المعارك الرسميه والان وكان
ضابطا برتبه والان انضم للشركه الخاصه
ويريد ان يحاربك جندي عادي لذلك
القوانين هنا متعدده وفي الشركات الخاصه
كل شيء جائز نعم
اثرت الى بلوك بلاك بوتر وهنا ننتقل الى
الدكتور حافظ هذه من الاشياء التي دائما
تذكر يعني ليس للامريكيين ان ان يعيبوا
ذلك على روسيا في حين ان لديهم شركات
امنيه خاصه نريد ان نفهم همم اسباب
الانزعاج الامريكي من ذلك الشكل
والتاكيد على انها مرتبطه بوتن بالرئيس
الروسي بشكل خاص
مرحبا سيد محمد شكرا على الاستضافه الا
الفرق
قانونيا يعني
برنس اللي هو الرجل الذي بدا بلاك ووتر هو
الان موجود في ابو ظبي
وهنا قضايا كثيره ضدها في الولايات
المتحده الفرق اساسي
الاطار القانوني لهذه الشركات في الولايات
المتحده لك الحق ان تبدا اي شركه مهما
كانت همم قد تكون شركه عسكريه
وتقدم خدماتك للجيش الامريكي ولكن هناك
ضوابط واضحه في القانون الامريكي لا تسمح
لك انك انت تمشي مثلا وتدخل في حروب اهليه
الى اخره بطريقه غير مراقبه هناك رقابه
وهناك همم
قواعد قانونيه واضحه تتعامل معها كشركه
في مشكله واجنر ان هي شركه
في ضبابيه كبيره حواليها وهذا يعني مقصود
هو ليست فقط عدم وجود معلومات ولكن مثلا
شركه غير مسجله في في موسكو في روسيا
الشركه
ليس هناك قانون في في في روسيا يسمح لهذه
الشركات بالتواجد ليس هناك عقود واضحه
بينها وبين الجيش الروسي هي تستعمل كدراعه
غير رسمي
للتدخل في بعض المناطق اللي هي تريد موسكو
همم ان ان ان تمد نفودها في هذه المناطق
ولكن بدون ان تتحمل العواقب السياسيه
والقانونيه لذلك
فهي يعني شركه اقرب يمكن اقرب شيء الواحد
ممكن يصل بها هذه الشركه او الجماعه هذه
هي كانها انت تخيل مثلا
القاعده او الدواعش
ولكن بطريقه
تكون وراءها احدى الدول الكبرى
وعضو في مجلس الامن الدولي يعني تصور انت
مثلا ان داعش او القاعده وراءها حكومه زي
الولايات المتحده او روسيا تحميها توجهها
تمولها بطريقه او باخرى حتى التمويل الذي
تعتمد عليه واجنر
ضبابي جدا غير معروف كثير منها ياتي من من
شركات خاصه ولكن نيابه على حكومات مثلا
هناك تقارير كثيره تتحدث على ان دخول واجن
في ليبيا مثلا كان ممول من الامارات من
ظبي
وقد اندر حتى البنتاجون ااا مراكز دراسات
الامريكيه في اكثر من مده باكثر من من
تقرير في على هذا الموضوع يعني مثلا ابو
ظبي تعتبر حليفه للولايات المتحده ولكن
مستعد ان تمول شركات زي وجنر في ليبيا وفي
مالي همم
افريقيا الوسطى في السودان يعني هذه هي
المناطق التي تريد موسكو
ان تكون متواجده فيها ولكن بدون طريقه
رسميه بدون الاعتراف بتواجد قوات روسيه في
هذه المناطق ولكن اسمح لي دكتور يعني
الاعلام الامريكي يركز بشكل خاص على ان
هذه المجموعه مرتبطه ببوتن بشكل خاص هو هو
هو هو الزعيم المخفي لها ما دليلها على
ذلك
الادله هذه كلها ادله مخابراتيه ولكن مثلا
في العالم ممكن يعني انت تلاحظ ان العلاقه
الخاصه اللي هي بين الرجل الذي بدا واجمل
ورئيسها الان وبين بوتن يعني في صور في
اييي تعاملات واضحه بيناتهم كالون لهم
علاقه خاصه هناك ايضا ادله استخباراتيه
تتحدث على ان هذه الجماعات يستعملها بوتن
همم بطريقه مباشره حتى لا يضر ان ان ان ان
ان ان ان يعني يتقيد همم قواعد الجيش
الروسي
فهذه الجماعه مستعده ان تتحرك بطريقه
مباشره وبسرعه حسب الاوامر التي تعطي لها
تمويلها ايضا لا ياتي من الطريق الرسميه
من الحكومه الروسيه طرق التمويل زي ما قلت
لك كثير منها اجرامي مثلا عندهم حمايات
لمناجم الذهب في افريقيا عندهم في ليبيا
عنده ويسيطرون على مناطق من من النفط
كبيره يعني ابار كبيره من النفط في ليبيا
هناك همم
يعملوا في الاسلحه في تهريب الاسلحه في
تهريب الكثير من الامور يعني
هذا يعطي شخصيه زيبوت الحريه في ان يستغل
هذه الجماعه بطريقه غير مباشره ولا يتحمل
مسؤوليتها سياسيا امام العالم واين يكون
خارج اطار القانون الروسي والقانون
والقواعد العسكريه للجيش الروسي هناك مثلا
همم الدكتور عاشور غير واضحه هي طبيعه
العلاقه مع الجيش الروسي يعني مثلا دخول
في حرب اوكرانيا فسره كثير من الخبراء على
انه دليل ضعف ودليل وهن في الجيش الروسي
سمحا بايه ان ان ان ان ان تدخل على الخط
فهل هل الصوره واضحه امكانيه التنسيق بين
الجيش الروسي وفاجنر وهناك
حساسيه ربما في الفتره الاخيره وفقه ما
قاله الامريكان على الاقل
وليس ضعف لكن هو تقدم خدمات لا شك للنظام
اكثر من الجيش هي بينها وبين العسكر
النظامي مشاكل الكبرى ومشاكل وليس فقط في
موضوع الاوكراني في موضوع في موضوع السوري
لو تذكرون معركه خشام الشهيره في دير
الزور حين واجهت قوه فاجنر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وتم الهجوم على بعض همم
المواقع التي كان فيها قوه رينجرز قوات
خاصه ومعهم همم بعض قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وفي خلايا فضل الاشتباك
الامريكيه ارسلت لحميم موقع القياده
النظاميه الروسيه وقالت لهم اسحبها هذه
قوات روسيه همم هذه لكنه
ظهر همم روسيه وبالتالي يسحبوهم والى
سندافع عن حلفاء الذين هم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه فبراير فبراير 2018
عشان اذا لم تجد شيء همم
هذه اشاره غريبه حتى حتى الجيش الروسي
حاول ان يتقدم نوعا ما على هذه على هذه
المساله هو قال لهم ليس لدينا قوات في
المنطقه تفضلوا ارسلوا اليهم مره ثانيه
هنا قوات روسيه ونحن نهاجم قالوا لهم
تفضلوا ليس هناك قوات لهذا هو تم فهذا كان
اشاره على ان داجن تتصرف بشكل شبه مستقل
واحيانا الجيش الروسي ده يريد ان يحميها
لكن الاهم هنا في الفتره الحاليه هو ان
همم
ومعه بعض المواليين الاخرين كانوا همم
يعني يهاجمون وبشده قياده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه كامله همم بعض همم المناطق
العسكريه همم مثل المنطقه الغربيه المنطقه
ال- همم الشرقيه المنطقه الوسطى عفوا همم
هؤلاء تم الهجوم عليهم بشكل كبير ويزيحوا
من المشهد همم وكان هناك تصور ان همم
هذه التقطير لاننا نحن الواحدين الذين
نتقدم بينما النظامين يتراجعون هذا كله
بسبب نابليغوجن يريد ان يكون يحل شويه
يعني يكون وزير الدفاع مستقبلا همم فهذا
هو الهدف يعني همم فالعلاقه شديده التوتر
همم ما بين هؤلاء التغيير الاخير الذي حدث
هذا رابع تغيير في قياده العمليات صرافه
تمت ازاحته وهو الجنرال الوحيد لقد الوحيد
الذي كان همم فيوجن ومعه حديثه وقديره في
همم رئيس جمهوريه الشام هم الذين كانوا
بيمتحنه الوحيد همم حتى بعد التراجع في
خصون كانوا يمدحونه همم ففي هذا الاطار
التغيير هذا معناه انه فيوجن ربما نفوذه
وحضور سياسيه تقل عن همم لانه الذي يعين
هو رئيس الاركان قسيمه وهو كان هدف له
كذلك فالعلاقه مع العسكر ليست جيده مع
السياسيين جيده للغايه همم لكن النقطه
المتعلقه بالشرعيه وهي هامه لانه لا يمكن
ان تدخل السجون الروسيه وتجنب من داخل
مدانين بجرائم قتل بجرائم اغتصاب بجرائم
سرقه بالاكراه وتعطيهم عفوا وتاخذهم
وتسلحهم وتدربهم وترسلهم الى اوكرانيا
بدون موافقه سياسيه ثم بعد ذلك هو الفيديو
الذي عرضته وهو يقول لمن انهى عقده من
هؤلاء المدانين بعد سته اشهر انتم احرار
تعودون للمجتمع ولكن لا تغتصبوا يقول لهم
هذا لا تغتصب النساء لا تشربوا كحول ولا
تتعاطى المخدرات
وانتم احرار المضاده انهم يقولون هذا نريد
المجتمع ان يريد ان ننهي مهمتنا في
اوكرانيا فهذه الطاقه
ولا يمكن ان تحدث لان كلها مخالفه
القوانين لا يوجد ما هي المحكمه التي
اعطيت لها عفوا او همم الحقتهم بالجائشه
وهذا كله سياسي يعني خارج القانون النقطه
الاخيره مع عبد الله بلاك ووتر في النهايه
كما تفضل همم همم اساميه الضيف انه همم
انت في الاخر همم اودينت بعض اتباع عقدين
ودين بقتل عراقيين همم اكثر من 17 عراقي
هو دينه في الولايات المتحده وفي السجون
الان طرق ان تغير اسمها ست مرات وفي
النهايه شركه مسجله وتابعوني اما همم
النقطه الاخيره هي صارت الان شركه علانيه
هي ليست في همم لديها مقر في ثانويه جورج
جورج
مبنى كبير للغايه الاول بعد ما كان يعلن
له ماذا يقولون ويعلن انه رئيس هذه الشركه
همم فالان الوضع ليس في الظلام يعني واضح
للغير
بدات مجموعه مسلحه ونفذ مهام في الظل
ووصلت الى مستوى
جيده التدريب والتسليح تساند الجيش الروسي
وقد اثار تصنيف الولايات المتحده لها
منظمه اجرام دوليا اثار الحديث عن حقيقه
قوتها العسكريه وطبيعه تسليحها ونطاق
انتشارها
لا تعد فاجنر شركه تقليديه واحده بل هي
شبكه من المنظمات التي توفر مقاتلين
للتاجير حسب تقرير لصحيفه واشنطن بوست
وترتبط عمليتها ارتباطا وثيقا بالمجتمع
العسكري والاستخباراتى الروسيه
يملكها رجل الاعمال
ومقرها الرئيسي في مدينه سان بطرسبورغ
الروسيه
تحول اتفاقنا خلال الاشهر الماضيه من قوه
نخبه صغيره الى تشكيل متعدد المستويات
بحجملك في اوكرانيا حسب وول ستريت جورنا
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي اكد انا لديفاك نار الان ما
يقارب 50,000 فرديا منتشرين في اوكرانيا
بما في ذلك 10,000 متعاقد واربعون الف شخص
مداني بجرائم جنائيه لا توجد معطيات محدده
بشان العده والاعتاد كما ونوعا لميليشيا
مجمل الدراسات والتقارير توضح ان
التسريحها مرتبط بالترسانه الروسيه وما
تفرضه طبيعه المهمه اليها وقد كشفت تحقيق
نشارته منظمه مؤخرا ان موسكو ارسلت الى
ليبيا خلال الاعوام الاخيره مئات من
ميليشارج
جوادتهم بطائرات ميغ 29
وصواريخ ارض جو واعتاد عسكري ضخم تقول
الاداره الامريكيه انفاق النار تتلقى
اسلحه ثقيله ومتوسطه من كوريا الشماليه من
بينها شحنه صواريخ وقذائف مصادر في
الاداره الامريكيه تقول ان مؤسس الشركه
ينفق اكثر من 100 مليون دولار شعريا
لتمويل عمليات فاجنر في اوكرانيا وحدها
عملت ڤاجنه في حوالي 30 دوله ولديها
معسكران للتدريب في روسيا وفقا لبحث اجره
مركز الدراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه في
واشنطن بدات العمل لاول مره ابان ضم روسيا
لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ثم ظهرت في سوريا لدعم نظام الاسد منذ عام
2016 خصوصا حول حقول النفط في دير الزور
وتنشط في ليبيا منذ عام 2016 في دعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر كما تنتشر في بعض الدول افريقيا
كجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى ومدغشقر وموزمبيق
والسودان وكان اخر انتشار لها في مالي بعد
انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من هناك كما ان
لها وجودا ايضا في بعض دول امريكا
الجنوبيه
كل هذا النشاط والعمليات لم يمر دون ان
تتعرض فاجنر لعقوبه سواء من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه او الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
سيف الدكتور
في سوريا تفعل ذلك ايضا في ليبيا على ما
يقال في افريقيا
لديها شركات وهميه تقوم باستخراج الذهب
والالماس
ولديها نسبه من هذه
الثروات موضوع التمويل كيف هو بالنسبه
انت قلت بنفسك ان قوات باك نار
تشارك في حراسه الشركات التي تستخرج النفط
والالماس والذهب وهم يحصلون على الرواتب
على هذا الاساس ويشترون الاسلحه التي
يمتلكونها الان واعتقد ان الاتحاد
هي مرتبطه بان الولايات المتحده
وتشكيلاتها لا تستطيع ان تتنافس مع اي دول
اخرى او مع اي شركات خاصه مثل فاجنر تكون
ضد الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده
تحصل على الضربات قاسيه همم
استطاعت اي قوات افريقيه بتحسين اوضاعها
وعندها وعندها يتهمون ان روسيا ان روسيا
هي من تقوم بهذا في الواقع ان الحكومات في
تلك الدول هي من تختار الشركات التي تدافع
يا نهار رسميا
وهذه الدول رسميه ايضا لذلك ان نتحدث ان
القاعده كانت نظيفه ولن ولم يملها احد
عندما كان الامريكيون يمولون القاعده
وايضا في سوريا داعش كان يملها
الامريكيون في حربهم ضد بشار واا من الخطا
هنا ان نتحدث ان ضاقنا لا يجوز ان نتحدث
الكذب عن بعضنا هي شركه حربيه خاصه عام
هذا حقيقي وهي همم
انضمت لتحرير اوكرانيا من الارهابيين في
نظام كيف الذين كانوا يقتلون الشعب
الاوكراني طوال ثمانيه سنوات وهم الان
يقصفون تلك المناطق بالاسلحه الامريكيه
ويقتلون المدنيين الابرياء في جورنافقه
وكيف والامريكان يقدمون الاسلحه لهذا
النظام هاي مرض وهايبرز
هو يقوم بتقديم الاسلحه ويريدون ان يقدموا
الدبابات حتى يستمر بقصف المدنيين
الابرياء لذلك من هو الارهابي من يحارب
المدنيين او من يحارب بجانب الجيش
الرسمي يجب ان نختار الجانب السليم
اسمعني اسمح لي مره اخرى
في موضوع اوكرانيا في موضوع اوكرانيا ربما
في موضوع اوكرانيا ربما يفهم الموضوع على
اساس ان روسيا متورطه هناك والمثل لا تعني
روسيا بشكل مباشر ولكن ما الذي يجعل
تدافع عن نظام بشار الاسد تدخل الى ليبيا
همم مع خليفه حفتر تذهب الى مالي وموزمبيق
وافريقيا الوسطى وغير ذلك هذه مسائل لا
علاقه لروسيا بها ما الذي يجعلها تذهب الى
هناك
انا بشار الاسد رئيس
حقيقه رسمي لروسيا عفوا سوريا
وطلب من القوات الروسيه ان تحارب داعش
التي نظمتها امريكا
وحتى يعيد النظام الديمقراطي التابع له هو
الرئيس الرسمي
وطلب من الجيش الروسي ولم يطلب من فايده
موضوع اعاده النظام الديمقراطيه هذه
المساله ساتجازها ولكن هو طلب من الجيش
الروسي ولم يطلب من من
نعم انت محق هذا سليم
ولكن في سوريا هناك شركات خاصه ايضا وهنا
قوات عسكريه خاصه
وهم من طلبوا من قوات ان يحرسوا ال ابار
النفط المتواجده هناك وهذا حقهم الشرعي
ربما سيد حافظ
ابتلاعك على الملف الليبي تحديدا يعني
مثلا ماذا كان دورها تحديدا في ليبيا حتى
ناخذ على الاقل فكره
خارج السياق الاوكراني
وضع في ليبيا كان واضح وهو مسانده خليفه
حفتر في محاوله سيطره على ليبيا واحتلال
العاصمه وكان ذلك زي ما قلت لك بتمويل من
الدول التي كانت تساند او دوله معينه اللي
كانت تسند خليفه حفتر وكانت تطمع في انه
يستطيع ان يفرض سيطره عسكريه على ليبيا
وهي الامارات التي ايدت حفتر بطيران
واسلحه على مدى السنه التي تورط فيها في
القصف المستمر على العاصمه واللي ذهب
ضحيته الاف كما تقول الامم المتحده
وهجر اكثر من 200,000 شخص في العاصمه بسبب
هذا القصر المستمر حفتر لم يكن له جيش
يعني كل هذا الكلام ان هو يقول جيش ليبي
كلام غير حقيقي ولا علاقه له بالواقع هو
يقول مجموعه من الايات
انه لم يستطع ان يوفر عدد كبير من الجنود
لفال ذلك يعني ليس هناك قابليه حتى في
المنطقه الشرقيه التي يسيطر عليها
ان الناس مستعده ان تطورت في قصف عاصمتهم
او قتل ابناء الوطن فلذلك كان عنده همم
قصور كبير في عدد الجنود والاسلحه ولذلك
دخلت الامارات بتسليحها وتمويلها لمجموعات
فاجنر التي كانت هي همم
القوات اللي على الارض اللي وصلت الى
ضواحي طرابلس لذلك السيد تبون الجزائر كان
يعني له كلمه مشهوره ان انا لن نسمح بشركه
بمرتزقه رؤوس ان يسيطر على عاصمه عربيه
ولذلك كان هناك حراك في الجزائر لمحاوله
السماح للجيش الجزائري بان يتدخل ولكن
تدخل تركيا بعد سنه من القصف المستمر على
العاصمه لح همم
طرابلس واد دفع بواجنر الى الى الحدود
اللي هي موجوده فيها الان لان نصف ليبيا
يعني لكن السؤال الامر الاساسي سيد محمد
ليريد ان ان نركز عليه وهو ان العقوبات
الامريكيه او هذه همم تصنيف الامريكي
هناك واقعيه في الفهم في واشنطن ان هذه
العقوبات يعني من الصعب ان ان ان ان ان ان
ان ان ان ان ان ان ان تفرض حقيقه على ارض
الواقع الا عن طريق محاوله قفل التمويل
ولذلك موضوع التمويل وهذا الانتشار الواسع
اللي هو انا قرنت مثلا التمويل القاعده او
داعش اللي هو ياتي من من من امور كثيره
اغلبيتها اعمال اجراميه
هو هو الهدف الاساسي من العقوبات
الامريكيه ايضا هناك طبعا اشارات واضحه
للدول اللي هي او الحكومات التي موته
فيعني مثلا دوله زي الامارات قد
تواجه في المستقبل تحرك قانوني وفي البر
في الكونجرس الامريكي ضد تمويلها لوادر
مثلا
طبعا وارد يعني الولايات المتحده الان
عندها الاطار القانوني الذي يسمح لكثيرين
من من مساله الدول والاطراف التي
جلبت او او ايدتنا بما فيهم مثلا حفتر
اللي هو امام الان القضاء الامريكي في
اكثر من قضيه بتهم همم ارتكاب جرائم حرب
لكن سياسيه زي ما روسيا تريد التمويه
والغموض في موضوع واجنر لا تريد ان تعترف
بحقيقتها او انها شبكه يعني من من
الجماعات المتداخله التي تمثل
اليد الخفيه لموسكو وتريد ان تبقي على هذه
الغموض
وتجد طبعا كثيرين اللي هم يحاولوا الدفاع
عنها
باسباب
وتفكير ومنطق يعني اعوج كما نش- كمان
نشوفه الان لكن ايضا هذا يعطي مثلا دوله
الولايات المتحده او اوروبا
القدره في ان يقصف واجنبر بدون ان يتورطوا
في انهم قصفوا قوات روسيه كما تفضلت حضرتك
من قليل الحديد على سوريا عندما قصفت
الولايات المتحده قوه واجنا في سوريا
وقتلت مئات منهم لم تستطع موسكو ان تتكلم
على قوات روسيه قسفت
فهذه هي ال- ال- ال- ال- يعني هي نعم همم
موسكو قد تستغل هذه هذه الضبابيع ولكن
ايضا الولايات المتحده واوروبا تستطيع ان
تستغل عدم اعتراف موسكو بهذه القوات
لقصفها
وانهاء دواجدها في مناطق يعني انا اعرف
مثلا انه واشنطن مستعده
انها في في درجه معينه لو زادت نفود وجنه
في ليبيا الى درجه فوق حد معين انه هو
مستعدين نقصفه وان يقصفوها بقوه وبشده همم
فهذا دائما موجود يعني ورقه هذه دائما لكن
هم يستغلوا مثلا في منطقتنا العربيه
يستغلوا الاطلاح
لمد اليد الروسيه في سوريا وفي ليبيا او
في الشرق الليبي ولا هي واللي هي الطرفين
اللي مضلين على شرق المتوسط اينما تتواجد
كل هذه
الثروات النفطيه والغازيه التي همم يعني
ما زال هناك فيها خلاف في هذه المنطقه
طبعا كما تعرف الغاز والنفط شيء مهم جدا
الى روسيا همم
انها لا تريد ان يكون هناك مثلا طريق اخر
الى اوروبا عن الغازي يعني همم اوروبا الى
فتره قصيره همم يعني معتمده اعتماد كامل
على الغاز الروسي لو فتحت مجالات اخرى
للغاز هذا طبعا يقلل من اهميه روسيا
لاوروبا فهناك اسباب كثيره همم تجعل من
موسكو او من بوتن همم يريد ان يستغل هذه
القوات بطريقه او باخرى بدون همم ان
يعطيها شرعيه او غطاء سياسي او الى اخره
الدكتور عمر عاشور حول
الكفاءه القتاليه يعني انا اعطيك مثلا
رايي لبعض الخبراء همم يقولون بان همم
قادره على التحرك الموضوعي في في مكان
معين وفي زمان معين ليست قادره على معارك
كبرى ولا معارك طويله ال- ال- الابد هذا
يقول خبير عسكري روسي اسمه سرجي بروستاكوف
وايضا همم باسكال همم بونيفاس عفوا مدير
ال ال المركز الفرنسي للابحاث
الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه يقول بان همم هي
قادره فقط على معارك محدده جغرافيا وزنيه
كيف تنظر الى هذه المساله هو صحيح ولكن لا
توجد شركه خاصه اعلام الشركه عسكريه خاصه
اعلم بها تستطيع ان تطير جابها بحاجب داخل
لا توجد همم ليس لديهم القدرات همم لفعل
ذلك همم صحيح هذا الكلام لكن هذا جعلهم
همم يعني تك تك في سبيل لديهم قدره
تكتيكيه عاليه
ولديهم قدره عملياتها عاليه ليس لهم قدره
همم استراتيجيه لانه ليست جيش حقيقه يعني
هم ما زالوا يطلبون يطلبون الاستناد
المدعي من القوات الروسيه
والتصحيح وكل من الجيش الروسي التسليح 29
لديها طائرات نعم اذا اذا سلاحها جزء من
السلاح الرسمي الروسي لكن هو سلاح رسمي
الروسي له درجات يعني هو يعني الجندي
العادي الروسي سلاح 81
القوات الخاصه تصليحها افضل ما هو موجود
فهم يقتلبون جدا من القوات الخاصه ويعملون
مع القوات الخاصه يعني سقوط مقاطعه
المهندس كامله في الصيف الماضي همم تركوا
الحرس الوطني اللي هما ليس النخبه وبعض
العناصر الاخرى همم
يسمى بالفارق الاول والفرق الثاني همم
يعني في المقدمه ليشغله القوات
الاوكرانيات الذين لديهم قدره على
المناوره الهجوميه ولديه مساحه
ولديهم خبره طويله هم الذين عملوا
الالتفاف في في تشكيله وانهوا وان هو
العمليه بهذا بهذه الطريقه تكتيكيه عاليه
ليست هذا شركات اخرى اعرفها هم يعني في
مقاربه فعلا
قدره تكتيكيه عاليه لكن ليست لديها قدره
على استراتيجيه واضحه يعني همم
همم وايضا لدي هم سمعتهم انهم شديد الباس
وشديد الوطن يعني كما تعرفي في الحاله
السوريه الجندي النظامي الذي حاول ان يهرب
في معركه تدمر مع داعش همم قطعوا راسه
علنا همم محمد اسماعيل اظن كان اسمه كان
جندي نظام كنا نتمنى الاول انه اثير من
داعش لكن كان جندي النظامي سوري همم
الجندي الاخر الذي في المدان الذي تجند
عندهم ثم قرر الفرات ثم ذهب الى كيف ثم
استبدلته كيف همم باقرا القران الشام
وراسه همم
احدهم هرب الى النرويج اعتقد النرويج
اعتقد نروج
وكان مستعد حتى للحديث عن بعض
جرائم الحرب في التي تورطت فيها ساذكر
البلد التي نقطه هنا هنا يعني هذه القدره
العاليه على التكتيكات واداره العمليات
ليس اداره استراتيجيه كامله
همم لكن اقول انا بمستوى رسمي فان لدي
خبره ثمان سنوات في هذه المعارك مع
الاوكران وبالتالي استطيع ان اكون يعني
منافس له او حتى وزير الدفاع همم مع هذه
الشراسه الشديده في ال- همم مع التمويل
المفتوح مع القوه العدديه انه في في
النهايه ال- الجيش الروسي كانت لديه ازمه
قوه ازمه تعريف قوه في النهايه لم يستطع
يعني يسيطر على المناطق التي يحاول ان يحت
لها هذه
الاعداد القليله نسبيا انا همم فعلا هو
الشرطه النرويجيه في الرجل الى
وطلب اللجوء شكرا لك دكتور عمر عاشور شكرا
ايضا لضيفنا من موسكو فيكتور لتوفين وشكرا
لضيفنا من واشنطن الدكتور حافظ لغويل
كالعاده ننهي هذه الحلقه بتغريدات في
موضوع هذه الحلقه نبدا بتغريده الكاتب
الليبي عبد الرزاق العرادي يقول فيها
الخبر ليس تصنيف الولايات المتحده لمجموعه
فن الروسيه كمنظمه اجراميه دوليه ولكن
الخبر ان امريكا ستعمل على تحديد الاطراف
التي تساعد بيننا واستهدفها زيارته وليام
بيرج الى طرابلس وبنغازي جمعت بين التحذير
والتعاون
الصحفي تنزاني ميلاد ايو غرد قائلا
الحكومه التنزانيه قالت ان التنزانيه
واسمه نمس تريمو توفي اثناء قتاله في
اوكرانيا بعد انضبابه الى مجموعه بينما
كان يقضي جزءا من عقوبته البالغه سبع
سنوات لارتكابه جرائم جنائيه غسان شربل
رئيس تحرير صحيفه الشرق الاوسط يقول زعيمه
هو العدو الاكثر للغرب انه اكثر من كارلوس
وسليماني و بن لادن والبغدادي انه يتكي
على روسيا وصورتها وترساها ويصعب على
امريكا ان تذهب مباشره
غير مصنفه منظمه همم ارهابيه لماذا تتسائل
تقول احدث تصنيف الامريكيه لها منظمه
اجراميه هو خطوه اولى لكن هذا لا يكفي هذه
ليست جرائم عاديه انه ارهاب محض عابر
للحدود
وننهي بالنائب البريطاني عن حزب العمال
ستيف
ريد التي يقول في تغريده له صدمت عندما
علمت ان حكومه المحافظين ساعدت
الاوليغارشيه الروسيه التي تراس مجموعه
مرتزقه فاجنر الوحشيه التابعه لبوتن
للتهرب من العقوبات واسكاتي صحفي
البريطاني من خلال المحاكم البريطانيه
بهذا نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا
يتجدد الخميس المقبل باذن الله
وسيناريوهات جديده في امان الله
[موسيقى]